record this [ __ ] again cuz I [ __ ] it
all up cut my hair people look at that
huh
yeah Korean gangster or backward Chinese
cook hello hey what's going on YouTube
now growing up when I was a kid I got my
ass beat all the time and honestly if
you're Asian you know what I'm talking
about the death threats now most of the
time when I got my ass beat it was
usually because of three reasons one I
thought it was smarter than my parents
no they got so this is just a dream too
I would talk back for no reason
three I would live for no reason 2.7 GPA
is good here's the thing every kid who
got that ass beat growing up tried to do
this at least once in their life and
what fed you uh it's the I stood up to
my purse because I said I wasn't gonna
take that [ __ ] anymore now has it worked
out for any kid ah never but nobody told
us that [ __ ] growing up we thought we
were [ __ ] geniuses like no more and
they were just gonna be like I didn't
know you cared that way I didn't have
been known so let me tell you about the
first and last time I ever stood up to
my parents now these type of ideas don't
come out of nowhere and I've got this
idea from a commercial I was in junior
high at the time I was at home watching
TV and I remember the first time that
commercial ever came on it was all black
and white and super dramatic and there
was a moment right before he was about
to get the [ __ ] slapped out of him and
said child abuse you don't have to take
when I saw that you know what I thought
to myself I don't have to take it at
that very moment because of that
commercial I was empowered but I [ __ ]
up on something my dad got really pissed
off at me and I decided I was gonna use
the car I run to my room all pissed off
I slam the door
my dad opens up that door says your dad
then suddenly the commercial popped in
my head and I don't know what came about
me suddenly the Holy Spirit of dumbass
took over and I said that's child abuse
how about the tight at that moment when
those words flew out of my mouth I
looked at my father and there was a look
on his face I had never seen before he
stood there exhale and walked right
outside my realm and at that very moment
I'll tell you right now I thought I
[ __ ] won I was like this [ __ ]
commercial was right I gotta take [ __ ]
no more [ __ ] all with luck we're not
gonna take it or at least that's what I
[ __ ] thought as I was [ __ ] dance to
myself like ah I won I heard my [ __ ]
door bust open and I turned around all
slow-mo and [ __ ] like
my dad was so [ __ ] angry he didn't
leave the room because he thought that
he learned something new he left the
room to go grab a bigger stick to what
my [ __ ] ass with this fool came back
with a lead pipe the size of Shaq's dick
[ __ ] swarm that [ __ ] like he was
trying to kill me I duck and write what
I did he shattered a shelf right behind
my ass and trust me at that very moment
I knew I [ __ ] up ah the death threats
I remember I have our mouths open and I
looked into his eyes and right when he
looked into mine he said that's a child
abuse stupid-ass [ __ ] commercial
you